and you know happy Easter happy Easter
bestow Happy Easter
[Music]
ss solve hit are coming in right there
oh yeah something
yeah there's something you could wash up
maybe two right there
imagine washing a baby
[Music]
a baby you know not a just a random kid
imagine that let's go back into the
music
[Music]
you might even scrub under that baby's
arms this is that kind of music
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's it that's it that's how you keep
that baby clean right there you got to
put on good music you know my mother
used to wash me some time when I was
young too Bryan Adams I remember when I
was young my mom would uh put us all in
the yard sometimes you know if we've
been out playing in the mud or just you
know fight and there's some times people
would in our neighborhood would burn
stuff in the ditch and um you know and
after the you know a couple days after
whenever it was just a bunch of ash in
the ditch or you know black ass or
something in the ditch we would do this
thing called dirty Donuts where we would
put like water all over our skin and get
out an ash and you'd get ash all over
your body and you would look I don't
know I guess kind of fun a little bit
but mostly just kind of covered in
charcoal and and I always remember that
that was kind of like a fun thing we
would do and then my mom would spray us
down with a hose out in the yard all at
once you know she would wash us all at
once and she would put on some Bryan
Adams sometimes in the house while she
would do it and I think it's probably
more fun you know I don't have any
children but it's probably more fun to
wash your children to music than just
sitting there washing them so but yeah
this seemed like the kind of music you
would wash a baby too and this is called
Seth saves spring from Isaac George oh
[Music]
yeah
oh yeah and that's definitely something
that you would clean a child too
what's up guys Happy Easter thank you
guys for being here with me today I hope
your weekend was good you know I'm down
here in Baton Rouge I'm in here in Baton
Rouge Louisiana and I'm down here by my
brother's house cuz he has a house down
here and he's married as a family I've
been here before if some of you guys are
on the youtubes you'll see you know you
know you know regular background that
you've seen before here whenever I'm
down here and and I've had a good time
man I have fun down here you know get
down here into the south and you see
people had enough cake today and you
know you don't want to the thing is with
me I'll tell you what happened with me
and desserts okay so here's the thing
I'll have a like it'll be a dessert at
the party and I'll be like I'll have a
little you know but then here's the
thing other people come to the party
late and they bring another dessert and
you don't want to let them down you know
I don't want somebody to just see me
just look at their dessert and walk off
you know like I'm some kind of you know
like I'm like a deadbeat dad you know
like I'm some kind of deadbeat dessert
dad you know who just looks at his son
and just walks off or moves away moves
to Akron or you know moves to you know
Norfolk you know I want to be you don't
want to be that participant and so if I
see a dessert and it looks good enough
you know I have to stay there and spend
some time with it and that's what
happened to me today I didn't plan on
eating a lot of desserts but next thing
you know somebody showed up with this
and somebody showed up with that and
then somebody you know somebody put a
bunch of animal crackers in the oven and
[ __ ] baked them and they were already
baked but now they're hot animal
crackers ha ha ha my defense is rest and
I'm guilty I'm about to prosecute my
stomach with about 30 in the matches and
I had some Mississippi mud so you know
this beautiful tall lady showed up with
a thing of Mississippi mud and I mean
God dang a thing was I mean this desert
container was probably a foot deep I
mean you could have got stuck in there
you could have lost a friend in there if
you had a small friend and so I had some
of that
next thing you know I've only had about
a little bit of regular food you know
maybe a small cut of ham you know I
think I had a small cut of ham and then
probably nineteen desserts and then I
can't even feel my face because I feel
like my whole face is just infested with
sugar and you know and then I just
started not feeling good and then I'm
depressed and I'm then I'm like change
into my running clothes and everybody's
like relaxing because it's Easter and
now I'm that freaking creep that's going
for a run on Easter and it's just you
know sometimes when you get into that
you know I get into that Bermuda
Triangle of deserts and it just can be
dark for me it can be really really dark
so so usually what I'll do is just
decide you know what today I'm gonna eat
whatever I'm just gonna go like that and
I wish we didn't even care about what we
ate you know I think there was a long
time ago probably back in the old days
you know out now everybody's so
concerned about their diets everybody's
on the diet I'm on this you know I'm on
Atkins I'm on Jerry Atkins you know I'm
I'm a senior you know I'm on keto
you know I'm on Kato Kaelin I'm on you
know only cheeseburgers during murders
you know everybody's on something I'm on
vegetables a mom you know broccolini
you know only only by my stepmothers
house my buddy told me is on that diet
I'm like that's not a [ __ ] diet like
you're gonna you're gonna star if you're
an idiot
but everybody's on some type of diet you
know somebody's like I'm on you know
water and limes like a that's not a diet
you know that's somebody that's you know
probably gonna die on an island you know
so some of this stuff isn't died isn't
diets sorry I call came in and I have a
ringtone of a teenager but yeah
everybody's on the diet everybody's on
something you know and it's just but
back in the old days you didn't you
weren't on a diet if somebody shot an
animal that's what you ate if somebody
killed a um you know a bushel of corn
that's what you ate somebody showed up
with a you know a little bit of Labrador
a couple of Labrador medallions that's
what you ate that was it I mean there
were probably years where people are
eating this or eating that
you know I'm not trying to be vile but
people were you know having German
Shepherd for dinner a long time ago in
the 1700s come on you know people were
having hain't you know a ham was you you
kill a pig and that's it that was it
somebody shoot a dove or an owl and that
was it
and that's what you ate there wasn't an
opportunity for all this dieting but now
you know once we get you know we get a
little bit more sedentary and that food
starts to build up in us so it's just a
different time now and so now you know
we're a little bit more concerned and we
didn't have mirrors back then that's
another thing maybe instead of diet and
we just get rid of all the mirrors have
we thought about that yet
I mean I've sometimes I wish we could
just have a big mirror burning you know
everybody just shows up and throws a
damn mirror into a big gorge one of
these empty gorges and just throws a
bunch of gasoline in there a turpentine
and the lights that [ __ ] up let's burn
these mirrors so who knows whose fat
who knows who who's out of shape who
knows who's feeling a little you know if
you lift your arm up and you can't lift
it up or if your underarm just you know
I got a buddy he's got his underarms
have kind of become tits under his own
and they still have all that hair on him
that underarm hair so he'll lift his arm
up and it's like this just hair tit kind
of pops out from under his arm and I
don't know why I don't know what's going
on with him he's like I'm thinking I
need a diet I'm like I think you need a
haircut on them tits first and go from
there but it's you know it's just I
before we were infected with all these
diets I think we used to enjoy our time
a little bit more and I guess if I could
look back on today a little bit I'll
probably wish I would have not thought
about you know calories and all of this
and that as much but I would have just
been you know more focused on the day
but we had we had I you know had a nice
weekend had a bunch of crawfish and
crawfish is just a that bit it's just a
fancy snail that's down the [ __ ] really
I mean that thing is it's like a shrimp
that's you know I mean I've talked about
it before crawfish is just like a shrimp
that some
from Rome it's basically a Roman shrimp
in those things I mean they are when you
get down here in Louisiana especially in
this time of year on Easter it's you
know it's not surprising to go to a
crawfish boil where somebody's boiling
400 pounds of crawfish 400 pounds and
you get that and eat that you know and I
guess when you do get down here in
Louisiana it is a little bit more like
you eat what's available you know you
eat whatever I mean you know I've talked
about it before but I had I had some
family members they killed two owls for
Thanksgiving a couple years ago you know
they were short on funds at the house
and you know the dad was selling tires
he used to sell used tires and you know
what you think people you a lot of
people nowadays they just get [ __ ]
new tires you know that use tire
marketers I don't know if it's
non-existent or what but but yet but he
would um you know they didn't have a lot
of money so they had to owls and they
fattened up a couple aisles and you
might ask why do they have two owls book
because one owl doesn't have a lot of
meat on it owl is basically like a
skinny woman in a you know in a fat in a
thick dress that's what it is
owls look fat they're not they look like
they store a lot of meat they're not
they're not at all so it's really a ruse
that a lot of these owls put on but
anyhow man my mother used to I remember
she used to hose us down and put on some
Bryan Adams and that was a good time
back in the day and I do think it's
probably more fun to wash your children
and music than it is to just wash your
kids like some kind of creep in the
silence you know like it's some kind of
damn you know I don't know I don't even
know it just sounds real creepy washing
your kids with no background music going
on
it sounds like real um like a crime or
something but anyhow welcome and to this
past weekend and it is April it is
spring it is April 2nd actually and I'm
down here in Louisiana I'm not gonna
make this a crazy wild episode because
you know it's Easter and I've been
relaxed and you know and I got them I
mean I had so much frosting today did I
would test I would tech I would test
positive
our tests positive for frosting if you
if you you know I think if you if you
took my blood type right now I would
probably say Swiss Miss I would come
back positive for Swiss Miss I'm just
you know I got that all in me I got that
confetti they cut my niece's made me a
cake and I'll be honest these little
[ __ ] can bake [ __ ] dude it was
but I ate you know something and that's
another thing these children show up
with baked goods you have to eat them
you know they didn't want you to eat it
like what is it it's chocolate chip I'm
like it's burnt you know it's and it
looks like a fish stick but whatever
that's what's going on man
and happy Easter to you guys and I
remember you know I think it's fun you
know hiding the children's baskets you
know my niece and nephews they got all
their baskets hidden and they you know I
get over here today and they're telling
me where they found it under the table
and this and that and I started thinking
about the Easter rabbit and you know
they were saying yeah Easter Bunny came
and I'm thinking how lucky it is if
you're you know back in the day whenever
they were you know audition and animals
or whatever to to get the role of the
Easter animal because that thing could
have been any thing about it I could
have been anything could have been
Easter Mongoose Easter swine Easter rang
a Tang I could have been anything but
it's you know that rabbit got that job
and if that rabbit doesn't book that
role then rabbits her they wouldn't I
don't think they would have had some of
the luxurious life that they've had
because think about it rabbits
they're basically squirrel fat squirrels
that [ __ ] a lot and have big eyes that's
what a rabbit is so just so to see them
booked that gig of being an Easter
animal and you know being that you know
being that uh they're like the Napoleon
of candy you know to see rabbits get
that gig and get out there it kind of it
kind of shaped their whole existence I
feel like in at least in America
you know I don't know what animal is is
the Easter animal in other countries it
could be a I don't know what it could be
they could have a Easter cricket in
Spain you know they probably have an
Easter kangaroo in Australia I don't
know because otherwise wrap it sir I
mean theythey
they're kind of a strange animal you
know they [ __ ] I mean they'll [ __ ]
anywhere you know they got that kind of
I mean they got that Jamaican blood in
them
I don't you have any friends that are
jamaican but man you you leave you know
you leave to Joe you you leave to
Jamaicans behind a you leave to
Jamaicans behind a shiver robe you'll
come back a little while later there'll
be 19 Jamaicans there Jamaicans like to
you know hit it and spray and make more
Jamaicans because Jamaicans are partiers
they like to have fun so if you have
another Jamaican around you and y'all
can make other Jamaicans you're like
[ __ ] yeah let's make a party you know
they're not [ __ ] to procreate and to
make a fam a lot of Jamaicans are like
let's [ __ ] so there's more people at
this party and that's how you know
that's how I otherwise rabbits I think
would have just been like that they
would have just been like you know this
kind of this animal that was out [ __ ]
all the time but instead you know
rabbits booked that role of the Easter
animal and they got that they have a
little bit more Joomla say quoi and this
French what does that even means Jim I
say quoi think it means French for like
pomp and circumstance so but that's a
lucky animal because it could have been
anything it could have been you know it
could have been a frog it could have
been the Easter frog and that would be
probably creepy to think for kids but in
some places that's probably normal in
very in Germany it might be an Easter
Frog I don't know what some of the other
countries do but but I grew up I
remember I didn't see a lot of I guess I
didn't see a lot of stray rabbits until
I worked on a farm I used to work on a
farm outside of Ferriday Louisiana which
is where Jerry Lee Lewis is from and I
didn't see a lot of stray rabbits until
I worked up there and and I do remember
actually when I was really young they
had a girl in our neighborhood this girl
named Doris splashy Doris people used to
call her because any time it would rain
and it would be puddles out on the
street
or whatever she would go out there this
little see-you-next-tuesday
you know what I'm talking about [ __ ] she
would go out there and put on these big
boots you know her dad's boots her
stepdads boots or some man's boots that
her mom was banging and splashy doors
would go out there and splash in all the
puddles until they like dispersed it was
like she wanted to get rid of the
puddles before the rest of the kids
could come and join him you know it's
kind of ah it was she was kind of like
the British you know she wanted to show
up and like you know ravage everything
and get it and get all the joy for
herself so she you know splashy Doris
would get out there and just just splash
these puddles in the you know
smithereens and and then by the time we
got out there we're like where are all
the puddles and splashy doors would be
in the distance just you know soaking
wet head to toe but acting like she
ruled the world but she made a they had
a bunch of not a bunch probably saying
maybe they had about 19 or maybe 30 may
be tall rabbits that came through one
year I don't even remember I think it
was like a cold year and a lot of tall
rabbits came through and she had a
lemonade stand this girl Doris so she's
out there selling lemonade or whatever
and she had a brother he was you know
this little [ __ ] he wasn't much I mean
he was kind of you kind of didn't even
care if he grew up or not he was like
that and and uh and these rabbits next
thing you know just attacked this
[ __ ] lemonade and I don't know if
these rabbits were from you know if they
had kind of a something in their system
where they wanted that lemon are they
wanted that sugar but until you've seen
about you know 19 or maybe even even 30
rabbits [ __ ] up a couple of kids I mean
you haven't seen that much you haven't
seen some of the joys in real life I
mean you know one of the greatest joys
is watching a big early to snow cone in
the rain and boy if you haven't if you
haven't held your body to that then what
have you done thank you guys for being
here with me though man it's nice to
just kind of sit and reminisce it's been
a long day man I eat so much food and
and I had just a whirlwind of days you
know I started off in New Orleans and
then I went over to to Mandeville which
is I got some family and came here to
Baton Rouge flying back to Los Angeles
tomorrow and I was thinking you know we
had we had our first guest last week and
I want to thank everybody for supporting
that Jay Mohr came in and a lot of
people me knew but first of all it
wasn't easy getting jay mohr in I was
excited that he came it wasn't easy but
I was excited that he came and we had a
nice time and I was nervous you know I
was so nervous and I was nervous sitting
there just like you know because I never
really haven't had anybody in the new
studio usually I record by myself so to
even have somebody there and but Jay was
really cool he was nice and friendly and
I was glad that you know that I made it
through that cuz I had a lot of anxiety
about it and I don't know if my anxiety
is that I don't know what to say
or I think honestly a lot of my
anxieties that I'm not going to be smart
enough to be in a conversation I think
that's where a lot of my fear comes from
and I think about it you know that what
if I start talking about something and
you know but I guess a nice person in
the conversation they're not going to
get so they aren't going to axe it I
guess there's a difference between
somebody being smart and acting smart
like I'm fine if somebody is smarter
than me you know I would be I would
imagine probably 80% of the world is but
if somebody acts real smarter than me
you know this straight-up Hogwart know
me and I'm just trying to survive then
that you know I guess that's some of my
fear is that I'm a being a conversation
and just trying to you know keep my hid
just you know it's like trying to just
grasp for air so that's some of my fear
I guess but we had some calls that were
they came into the that we're supposed
to be on the Jay Mohr episode but you
know as it flowed I didn't know if we
should like go to some calls or talk
about the news or anything so we just
kind of made it through it but I'm gonna
hit you guys with a couple of calls
right here and I want to thank again
Isaac George who sent in that song for
the intro that is Seth saves spring
and when trying to kind of meander
through a couple of these calls from you
guys that have come in over the last two
weeks and then we will you know we'll
make it through I mean this is the start
of spring this is April you know April's
that time it's like you know this is
like the rain it starts to dry up so you
know splashy Doris is probably getting
pissed wherever she is what if she's
like 35 now or something she's still out
there splashing that's crazy man
it's crazy to think the things you could
do when you're a kid if you do them now
you probably go to jail you run up to
somebody you don't know put gum in their
hair you could probably go to jail you
you you what else do kids do now just
throw rocks at it abandon house as an
adult well I guess even if you do that
as a kid you go to jail mmm what else do
kids do now oh just throw a tantrum at
the mall you lay down at the mall pull
your pants down and just scream on the
top of your lungs you probably go to
jail or get picked up by a shady man but
probably go to jail here's a call that
came in right here man I'm hit this
hotline there we go you know this is
Andrew calling you back I called last
week from South Dakota thanks for
calling Andrew from South Dakota and I
think I've been to South Dakota I
believe that's the Black Hills are over
there and you guys have that Mount
Rushmore and Mount Rushmore they should
diversify it a little bit I think they
need to throw on you know they need it
throw on some diversity on there you
know chisel chisel a couple more heads
on there or at least make it so that
some of the the founding fathers that
are up there maybe you put a t-shirt on
them one of them is wearing like a um
like a Manny Pacquiao shirt and one of
them is wearing you know like a Carl
Lewis or a new sane bolt shirt and you
know at least add some diversity to the
environment over there I think it'd be
pretty cool well let's hear more Andrew
thank you for calling I'm telling you
about my brother a nice weekend rock
climbing and you were asking about who
listens to your
your podcast first a little bit about me
I'm a I'm my doctorate I'm a nurse
practitioner are you an MP I think
that's what it's called as guests but
you're a nurse practitioner and I think
you know I don't know if I could be a
nurse because I couldn't take blood out
of somebody's body and not want it put
it back in I'm gonna kind of person
something if I take it I feel like I
should return it and even if they're
like no I want to get it tested I want
to donate it or whatever I feel like I
would try to sneak back in in the middle
of the night or if somebody was in a
coma and you know shoot it back into
them so that's one of the things I think
I would struggle with as far as Nursing
goes because a lot of these nurses they
take your blood out and they [ __ ]
sometimes they'll mail it off to a lab
like what are you some kind of like you
some kind of post mates vampire you
[ __ ] mail in people's blood around
and acting like you're normal and going
home and feeding your kids Chef Boyardee
something isn't right thanks for calling
more yeah and I work in a family
practice clinic in South Dakota so
you'll have patients from 2 years old to
102 and we just you know we see patients
and manage their medication this evening
when when I'll my call is on I got a
call from my mom she's 48 years old and
she's she's a nuclear medicine tech Oh
apparently that nuclear medicine textu
meet some men because if she only 48 and
your mother's calling you and you sound
at least you sound older than 17 or 18
me sound like a damn adult then your mom
was cracking eggs early lets go more lo
and behold she was a few so Theo
she called freaking out I had no idea
that that she listened to listen to the
podcast
she called freaking out saying was that
you calling in and so that's kind of
cool you got a you got a mom some do all
listening to your podcast every week oh
that's a cute thing man appreciate you
sharing that with me you know in a happy
spring-- to your mother because I'm sure
she probably listening as well you know
I got to see my mom today here at Easter
and I got to see my mom and uh you know
we had a kind of a sentimental moment
actually making me think about it Andrew
so I appreciate you sharing this because
now you're making me think and making me
feel
a little bit you know my mama I was
saying bye to her today and you know I
was talking last week up with on the Jay
Mohr episode about how you know my
mother never laugh you know and I don't
know if we ever have you know it just
the things were just stressed when I was
young and so we didn't do it it's just
there wasn't a lot of humor there wasn't
a lot of free joy around the house and
the TV shows we watch together we watch
some American Most Wanted and we watched
unsolved mysteries so I went to [ __ ]
and straight-up fear you know I'm saying
I'm wrapped up in the dark arts my whole
brain is just clouded up in that shroud
of murder and espionage and you know
long-lost family members and Amelia
Earhart I mean I swear to God every
episode of unsolved mysteries was about
Amelia Earhart and you know that and it
was kind of wild you know saying bye to
my mom today and you know sometimes I
wonder because I haven't you know I do
always you know I wasn't the most
happiest about my childhood you know I
didn't I didn't you know my childhood
didn't leave me with a lot of positive
feelings inside of myself that prepared
me or made me feel comfortable as I
became an adult they did not would ever
happen when I was young it just left me
with a lot of self-doubt a lot of
insecurity a lot of self-worth issues
and and you know things that I still
battle with I'm fighting but and I've
and you know as I've gotten older laid
off I realized that a lot of that was
because of my upbringing you know it was
just and I believe that my mother
probably did the best job that she could
and so I just I started to worry
recently well you know do I you know am
I am I ever even without knowing it
am I ever you know just you know have I
shown how about let my mother know that
I'm you know grateful that I'm you know
even if even if
even if my mother never did anything for
me you know at the very least somewhere
inside of me I have to be grateful that
which isn't true I mean my mother did a
lot for me but that that I'm grateful
that she made me you know and so
whenever she was leaving today you know
she gave me a hug and and I didn't let
her go you know I just held on to her
you know and I rode through that moment
of uncomfort where you would usually you
know it might be a little uncomfortable
and then we were in second hugs now
we're on the second well you know I'm
starting to get second hug syndrome
where you staying a hug too long and we
need to do this video and we thought
about it doing it last year where you
hug a family member who doesn't like you
and you got to hold on to them for eight
seconds and you record it and whoever
does the best one you know we give them
a prize and we're hopefully gonna do
that again soon because nobody's sent
any videos last year and that's that new
professional bull ridin hugging a family
member that doesn't like you for eight
seconds how long can you stay home but
so I'll hug my mom and you know I stayed
through that first uncomfortable moment
and then I'm riding a second hug so
we're now with me and her drifting into
some you know some new areas in that
second hug and then I stayed through
that second hug moment well you know
what hugs going on too long I was like
I'm staying in this hug and I stayed
through that her into that third hug and
I could feel her she started hugging me
back a little more you know and I knew
that you know I just knew for a second
that she knew that this was you know
just kind of a different moment I was
just trying to create a different moment
because I'll gets you know I'll just get
used to doing the same moments you know
the ones that are comfortable the ones
that that are comfortable the ones that
are comfortable maybe not even in a
positive way but just ones that are
comfortable for me that I'm used to and
so I was like I'm a change you know I'm
gonna I'm gonna ride through a couple of
hug breaks and then you know she was
leaving I just told her I said you know
I just wanted to thank you I just you
know sometimes I don't know if you know
how much I care about you and sometimes
I feel like I get so caught up in
dealing with some of my feelings from
growing up and you know and so am I the
problems and [ __ ] I feel like because I
know I'll get emo on this I know I get
email out here with you guys but I saw
some time I feel like I deal with some
of that so
that I forget you know that maybe I
don't let you know that in addition to
me you know you know figuring some of
the sound and thinking about it that I
you know I have always really cared
about you and you know because that's
true I mean even there are times if you
don't get along with somebody or you
even can't stay in them or you know in
your life
there's probably really there's probably
a part of you that's still know that
cares because you wouldn't you wouldn't
have as much invested on the other side
if you didn't think there was something
real positive to gain on the positive
side I'm probably not gonna hate
somebody unless I feel like man if the
tables were turned and we were in a
better position that I could really like
them but so I appreciate you sharing
that moment Andrew because you know it's
it's nice I think that's cool when you
find out that you and your mother have
some connection there are things you
guys like together
I mean it's wild I still like Bryan
Adams you know I still like Bryan Adams
everything I do do we follow you and cuz
you know we used to clean the house that
my mother used to make us clean the
house so that she used to spray us down
spray that soot off of us you know we
would look I mean we looked like we were
from another planet because when you get
in those ditches and you got it all that
Ash you get all that you get the black
and you get the grey and so you could do
some stuff around your eyes like you
know make a gray mustache or you know we
look like a little just just like
licorice critters when we come out that
ditch a mom we get to the door and be
like oh mom and she'd spray us down and
that was a good time but I proceeded
sharing that moment they you and your
mother hey you guys are listeners and
thank you thank you Andrew and I hope
you guys have a beautiful spring over ah
let's take this call came in from Jeremy
Jeremy here we go yo Jeremy from Jersey
want to play by my path weekend thank
you for calling Jeremy from Jersey and
I'll be in Hasbrouck Heights
New Jersey in a couple of weeks April
20th and 21st at bananas combat at class
hubba all right let's hear more on
Thursday I broke my foot playing
basketball oh you broke that foot huh
see you down a one hoof they call you
one hoof Jer
they you out there store can now you can
only play Center and you can only play
it on one leg this ought to be good
let's hear more here's the kicker
this coming Saturday I'm getting married
so you get married on that one leg mmm
see you got one foot in and you got one
foot out the door already that was
ridiculously sad homeward my fiance was
not happy about it say the least yeah
well she's not happy about it because
you're coming in clumsy you know this is
the time when you need to be shining
this is a time when if anything you need
to sprout or another leg you know or
sprout a second cop but you're out there
you you know you only got two wheels and
you blow in one of them out playing
hoops at whatever 35 like you said were
you supposed to be huh
you Kevin McHale you mugs you bogus who
are you supposed to be man you know you
ain't you starting out there at the YMCA
dawg shut it down you know sometime I
see minute and you know 45 year-old men
out there skateboarding going off of
ramps and shattering their spines and
I'm like well no [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
skateboarding for children what if I was
still doing finger paints all day in the
afternoon and you expect me to think you
know Picasso that you know because these
skateboarders men like all my Tony Hawk
fan well that's great but you're not
Tony Hawk he is what you are is a man
that's about to probably end up in a
wheelchair soon and then his wife's
gonna have to work all the time and make
that money and you're gonna be at home
in that chair eating TV dinners and
that's you know and that should or ruin
a marriage but anyhow thanks for calling
Jeremy let's hear more so about three
days
I should start feeling bad for me but
she's been taking care of me so step
very good girl Wow
so it took her three days to feel bad
for you yeah I could imagine that
because a woman do the wedding that's
everything that's all you just have to
look good that night the next day you
could lose your hair you could mail your
dick to another country
you could do anything after that but
that that wedding that's it you got to
show up you gotta have your if you have
tits on your arms you better give them
haircuts that's the night you got to
show up that wedding night after that
who cares okay a lot of women don't even
care if you go missing after that you
could you know you could disappear on a
cruise a lot of them don't give a [ __ ]
you need to show up for that night make
it illegal make it legit so they got
that alimony paper coming in you don't
need to have the big thing get the
pictures that's what you got to do
that's your responsibility as a man and
you out there [ __ ] shooting hook
shots you know out there at the DFW out
there at the American Legion playing on
the men over 35 year old team the
Rattlers were the Rattlers you don't
like the [ __ ] Rattlers most y'all
work at the bank okay so we got to
tighten up Jeremy let's hear more so
this past weekend was a bad weekend next
weekend it'll be a good weekend and then
on April 21st and coming it to you at
bananas comedy with my buddies damn and
I feel bad about making funny you know
well thank you thank you thank you I'm
excited you're coming out to bananas I
didn't know that and heard the whole
call and look hopefully you'll be better
by then that's what I'm saying you know
what obviously your wife is a good lady
if she's helping you already after three
days it does sound like you got a good
woman you know it sounds like you know
hopefully this is the only time that you
break up foot I mean things happen you
know they had a man somewhere you know
he he he was supposed to get married and
apparently the day before he was
supposed to get
married he married a different woman so
at least you're not doing that at least
you're just breaking your foot and you
got to look at the bright side I guess
but I'll see you in on New Jersey I
don't know if any of that even made any
sense brother but I'll see you in New
Jersey yeah oh and also if you got to
wear that boot at least deck that thing
out you know I'm out here I'm in a
crawfish boil today here in Louisiana
and the first time ever in my life I
seen a man with two you ever seen the
people they have so some of you if you
heard a you know you break one of your
tarsals are you bust a foot you got to
wear that boot you know you got that
Robocop unit that big it almost looks as
if you're going snowboarding but you're
not in the snow or anything you're just
you're in a regular area and this
gentleman he had to he had one on each
foot so he just you know he was cupid
shuffling everywhere and I've never seen
that before but just be thankful you
only broke one foot you could have broke
your neck and now you got to be you know
now you and your wife you got a you know
your wife has to you know you're gonna
be you know probably in a wheelchair
most of your life or in like a uniform
you know a robotic outfit so at least
you just broke your foot at least you
can still stay in there and tell your
wife you love her but at least stand up
even though I only got one leg I'd stand
up there on one leg because I don't know
if they if if Lee I don't even know if a
marriage is binding if you're on one
foot you might be able to you know
loophole your way out of that if you
have to but she sounds like a good woman
and I'll see you in New Jersey let's
take another call here here we go Theo
Joe from Pittsburgh Joe from Pittsburgh
thank you for calling Joe I caught
pinkeye up there in Pittsburgh one time
from a blow job actually and that was a
long time ago let's hear more I'm just
wondering if you're still doing that
meditation
masturbation where you're jerking on a
stick to your old ladies in their
apartments on Wednesday mornings well
that's not exactly what occurred Joseph
so if we want to look at facts let's
look at packs and you're talking about
orgasmic meditation and that is a kind
of a seminar group that I got involved
with where some people know about this
some people don't but it's you
look it up it's called orgasmic orgasmic
meditation and this where you meet up
with people and you pleasure them with
your hands you pleasure a lady you know
and they spray out kind of or whatever
and then you leave and it's like
supposed to like boost everybody's
spirits and that's sort of the abridged
version of it and I'll tell you more
about it another time but I'm you know
I'm in my brother's living room right
now and they got children around in the
distance you know some of them are
asleep but you know you never know that
when you talk about the dark arts if the
words will just kind of creeped out of
here out of your mouth into their you
know into their resting brains and I
don't want to be a part of that but
thank you for asking Jeremy and I Joe
and I will do that I'll talk about that
at a future spot here we go let's go to
another call man I'm sorry I'm just
jumping in all the calls here you know I
know it's just you know I mean I'm I'm
literally here at the dining table in my
brother's place and I don't want to you
know you just don't know if my voice is
bad or and around the house and keeping
people up here we go hey oh my name is
Lee I'm from Kingston Ontario Canada Lee
from Kingston thank you for calling me
man
it's a Lee from Kingston here we go I
got a little bit of a snafu here I've
been with my girlfriend for about a year
now
she doesn't participate in any cocaine
use oh so she alone that dust and Lee
apparently and here's that's another way
people will sometimes say that they own
that dust uh-huh
is by saying somebody else isn't you
know like you show up with your buddy
Karl and you're like hey this is Karl he
doesn't use cocaine that's basically
throwing Karl under the bus and it's
just a nice way of saying you do cocaine
but thank you for calling Lee I'm glad I
know that your lady doesn't do it
homework or any drugs for that matter I
got a date book this Friday to go to uh
I guess Nordic spa for a couple days
with it no
Spa now that's not like a trap to me I
mean if you've ever seen Game of Thrones
but a Nordic spa sounds like a trap you
get in the water you know you feeling
good they say they got all kinds of
special things in the water
ivorie meant you know juniper honey
cinnamon all types of stuff that's
supposed to get into your body and make
you feel good and then cut out a
[ __ ] shows up in deer furs and
[ __ ] you up a Nordic spa let's hear more
it's gonna be a little vacation I was
thinking about bringing some cocaine
along and dipping into that but I don't
want it to ruin ruin the time here I'm
wondering if you ever dip into that
while you're with a female that she
doesn't participate so I definitely
don't want to ruin the weekend and I'm
just wondering if you have any tips for
me or what you think I should how you
think I should attack this oh man I love
this call I love this call thank you
well look I tell you this you know you
do a couple of speed bumps and you start
you know you start just chewing on that
little antelope mouth meaning with if
you want a little bit of cocaine well
I'll do it I'll Lita you know I'll eat
the [ __ ] ball bag off a cabdriver
you know what I'm saying you know I'll
eat the [ __ ] I'll eat the damn tits off
a nun on some cocaine boy I don't you
know you could damn you could you could
wash somebody's ass with your teeth you
know I'm not trying to be too loud in
here cuz they got family in a distance
but boy you kidding me so I don't take a
bunch don't get a bunch out there
because you start doing a bunch and
you're sitting in the hot spa and they
got you start getting dehydrated in your
hearts beating fast that's awkward
you're gonna be like a senior citizen
then but you got to always you know
maybe do a bumper here then you know
chew on that frickin a little sugar
spout do what you got to do because that
thing you know that'll make it
not a Miguel you know that'll make it
I'll turn you know that cocaine will
turn your tongue into Magellan if you
know what I'm saying
that thing will make it I think I'll get
out there and look for new lands so you
might be able to treat your lady right
if you got a little bit of that dust in
you but but in your honor just be
careful you don't wanna pressure her
into doing it you got to be careful she
don't taste it on your mouth for your
face either and your face can't be
getting all numbed up and you guys go to
dinner you order a bunch of soup or you
order some crab and kind of you know he
starts you know just face-fucking a
crustacean like I've done some crazy
[ __ ] on some cocaine at dinner you know
I tried to eat a roll one time a bread
roll
I was so coked down man I couldn't even
I guess somewhere in my head I felt like
man I have to finish this roll like
everybody the table is gonna think it's
weird if I don't finish this bread roll
and that wasn't true I thought that in
my own head so I'm just trying to shove
this and it got to the point where it's
just me against this role it was it was
like a like a super it was like a
competition it was just me against it
well nobody at the table even gave a
[ __ ] in the beginning but by the end
they're like Jesus this dude will not
let this bread go and I was trying to
get that bread into me so that kind of
stuff can happen you just got to monitor
what's going on so I think you know have
a little hit here have a little hit
there but don't get Graham doubt don't
get Graham doubt and start you know
abusing your lady or you know trying to
start a threesome with somebody you know
the cleaning lady or that kind of [ __ ]
that's the thing
cocaine you'll have one plan you know
you'll have one plan but the next thing
you know you do too much you got 90
plans and you're naked and you in a room
by yourself somewhere you in the broom
closet and you got for your fingers in
your ass so just control yourself
control yourself because some people
they can manage their drug use they can
manage their alcohol I cannot I cannot
manage my drug use at this time in my
life but thank you for calling there Lee
I appreciate that
also I want to remind you guys that this
every episode is brought to you about
gray block pizza gray block pizza think
about think about Tom think of if you
were just trapped on a desert island and
a plane flew overhead and something fell
out of that plane and it landed right in
yo mouth that is grey block pizza that's
the magic of it and that's at 1811 Pico
Boulevard in Los Angeles and you could
be blind or you could be deaf or you
could have super senses and super powers
gray block get that hit our Sun all
right let's take this call right here
I'm gonna let you guys know too I got a
couple of dates I'll be in Tampa this
weekend so come out to Tampa the Dark
Arts tour we're gonna put those dates up
soon got a lot of neat cities you don't
know about yet that are gonna be on on
theof on calm slash tour t oh you are
here we go let's take this call here I
feel my name is Rebecca
I'm calling from Virginia hey Rebecca
and thank you for calling happy Easter
to you however I like to a middle school
and they'll take Louisiana if you are
familiar with the area oh yeah
Belle chase boy my friend of mine got I
don't know if he got rabies but he got
bit by something pretty hard alee over
there in Belle chase one time and that's
the kind of area where anything could
happen you know a lot of stray animals
and stray humans over there you know a
lot of adults sucking their thumb of an
air Belle chase a lot of people doing
flooring you know people do flooring
they floor this they floor that's the
thing you get into certain parts outside
of New Orleanians everybody does
flooring you want flooring people like I
got a floor they're like you want to
flow on you want double floors like what
the what is it you want floors on the
ceiling and so I'm saying you could do
then you could you could walk on your
hands and feel like you you know you
still got a chance with your feet you
could do flooring anywhere flooring over
the windows once you get outside of New
Orleans is everything is flooring and
that's the flooring belt but let's hear
more thank you for calling hearing you
talking about having children and a
previous high
reminded me of a dilemma I'm facing I am
going to be marrying absolutely amazing
person MA and oh my gosh I think about
of course having a family with this
person at that point wow that's a
nervous feeling uh for me it is but
let's hear more but I kind of struggle
with the idea of having our own children
when the option of adoption is available
you know I think that there is a lot of
ego that goes into having children and I
wonder if adoption is really the the
ultimate you know action of love sign of
love so I just wonder what your thoughts
on that are thanks for calling Rebecca
yeah that's uh you know I'm I'm excited
to hear that you found somebody that you
know means a lot to you and I wish you
the best of luck there yeah that's a
great question
I mean there's a lot of parents I see
that you know they I mean I see parents
that have children that are just almost
like you know they just get them all
decked out with nice cars and nice
clothes and it's almost like they just
the kid is like an extension of them but
almost more like an advertisement for
the parents I see parents that are seem
super involved with their children you
know and they they just you know they
just want to be a you know I guess you
can't help but want to be like a
obviously you need to be a provider but
they just want to be there for them and
they want to help them they just want to
give them the best opportunity to have a
comfortable life you know maybe to learn
from some of the things that they didn't
have as a child and then be able to
hopefully find some ways to offer those
to their kids but you know when it comes
to adoption I don't know you know I've
never had anybody in my family that's
been adopted one of my buddies has and
you know he talks about a little bit
sometimes you know I can't imagine what
that's like you know I have a friend
who does foster care and he fosters a
lot of children and that it's always you
know that brings you know that I bring a
tear to my eye sometimes thinking about
that you know when I see pictures of him
and you know him bringing him and his
wife bringing these people into their
lives and bringing these children in it
really makes me feel something but I
think you know you just asked your heart
about that kind of stuff you know I
don't know if it's egotistical to have a
child of your own if you think you can
be a good parent if you care about
raising children you you know it's
probably okay you know you could try to
do one of each
you could try foster chip care first to
see if it's something that you're good
at you know so I think it's nice of your
thinking about it I think it's nice
we're talking about it maybe there's
other people thinking about it you know
our mama I used to read that book Cider
House Rules all the time
and those kids out there you know they
you know they trying to you know if you
go into a foster place or a adoption
center you know all the kids they put on
like a nice shirt or if they don't have
a nice shirt some kids will put on like
a a vest or a cape you know I'm a friend
of mine one time saying he went to
adoption place and one kid he he didn't
even have a nice suit but he had like a
vampire outfit and this [ __ ]
dressed up like a vampire thinking he's
gonna get adopted I'm like damn you know
I don't know if people gonna want a
little vamp at the house so I don't know
what kind of you know haberdash and
guidance they have in some of these
joints so they might be able to use some
some help when it comes to even you know
clothes and stuff like that some of
these kids but I think it's a great idea
you know I think anything that we can do
to help is a good idea maybe one day I
would like to have it you know have you
know try and help if I can handle it
that's another thing you know it's like
can you handle it you know if you can
handle it and I'm sure after you ever
you know if you have one child of your
own if you do foster chip you know help
out some foster kids and maybe we'll get
an idea of it because I have also had
friends who have adopted kids if like
from other countries and some of that
[ __ ] has gone astray you know one of my
friends adopted a child from Russia this
little girl the girl burned her house
down and they don't tell you that when
you reading the pamphlet
child if they do arson so it's hit or
miss you know it's hit or miss out there
but what else man I mean you know I'm
gonna I think I'm gonna reel it in for
tonight guys and I don't mean that you
know I appreciate all you guys all you
guys support and for listening and being
supportive but it's just you know I'm
just in a tough locale here I got the
family they got people in the kitchen
right now doing dessert and stuff and
I'm out here talking about you know Rush
and children burn this [ __ ] down and
people jerking off and stuff so I just
don't know what's appropriate somebody's
heating up a I think some Totino's right
now thing a pizza rolls but you know I
might have to get me a couple of em
things but I appreciate the support I'm
excited to get some new guests in coming
up I'm excited to get home and get back
into the studio and keep things moving
over there I want to thank you guys for
just for tuning in this week and for
being a part of things I'm gonna wish
everybody a Happy Easter
and and we'll get back into the regular
regular flow of things this Thursday and
also those episodes it's going to be
we're gonna be going live to one
Thursday I believe with live rays and
that's a new app you can check out and
I'll put the link to them in in the
episode so you can just kind of see what
they're about in the information but
thank you guys for your support
hope you Easter was great hope you got
to spend some time with somebody loved
or even somebody who hated and if there
were somebody who hated I hope you held
on them for eight seconds and I hope you
caught a video of it man because I would
love to see that you guys be good
yourselves I bet you deserve it
that's it
[Music]
[Laughter]
happy april guys